[Music]
so actually
i know what you guys are thinking i like
starting that okay and you guys are
thinking
that [ __ ] can't they're not they
don't even want to be storm chasers but
actually you [ __ ] idiots and sexists
they they do
storms well you at you're actually
actually wrong about me because i don't
even think that people could chase
storms in the first place any people
they do you frown up you frown upon it
you think they shouldn't do it but there
were women in this in the storm chasing
unit in twister weren't there yeah
barely what's her name wait people
actually go to representation they go
towards the storm
yeah they drive towards the storm they
like seeing tornadoes on their instagram
feed you get some it gets them wet
people don't know
we're trying to break this stereotype
yeah the stigma is too much
natalie portman chased the storm in thor
oh
so there you go yeah see that's where it
started it's being depicted in media you
think she was the one who inspired a lot
of people i think i think twister
started it if i'm gonna be it did start
it with helen hunt helen hunt that's
what it is hell and how one hunt just
started for the cows that's for sure
yeah yeah but you know according to this
msn article male chasers have
historically grabbed much of the
spotlight okay so when a viral tornado
video pops up on the evening news and
social media it's not just stupid men
out there who are trying to film
tornadoes stupid women
[Applause]
traditionally dumb guy things
there's examples of women doing it they
have another traditionally dumb guy i
got one what the [ __ ] russian slap
competitions there's chicks in there
there's women doing it and they'd be
slapping the [ __ ] out of each other i
want to see a woman slap another woman
so hard that her teeth flies out yep
that'll happen i think it'll happen
right yeah i want to see a female monk
getting hit in the nuts with the [ __ ]
stickles yeah
that's training
yeah
female getting hit in the nuts huh guys
so i'm gonna show you guys a video
okay and you guys can tell me
if you guys think it's a guy in the
video or if you guys think that it's a
girl i could tell when a girl filmed
something
jokes on you steve i don't conform to
those gender norms
know we'll find out all right it's never
as good no audio that's a chick
oh [ __ ]
damn [ __ ] tornado whoa
that's a car
that's a truck oh it got right back on
dude it got right back on the wheels and
[ __ ] holy [ __ ]
and it's kept driving oh it just drives
on
it's driving all like nothing happened
my wow that was tight it's fast and
furious
you think to yourself that does look
like chick driving but i do think that
it was more like a guy behavior to drive
through the storm so here's what here's
where there was a giveaway right this is
the giveaway right here what is it it's
a trick driving
now you know oh my god yeah now you know
that was her father he she she passed
away
what yeah that's uh she passed away in
the driver's seat he's smiling then when
it cut to him
so no but this is all about raising
awareness because chicks do dumb [ __ ]
too and everybody thinks that it's just
it's not it's just dudes out there who
are like getting a huge [ __ ] camera
and they're lopsiding part of their
truck because it's such a big camera and
they got a jib arm on it and they're
like stretching out like 15 feet out
past the truck that's also chicks who do
that too right and just chicks when you
see those trucks getting fully reversed
pulled into a [ __ ] tornado
you know it's not just dudes it's
actually chicks it's not a chick that
sucks at driving and got lost
into the center of the store there is a
venn diagram here so there is some of
that crossover for sure no bart it was
intentional she was a scientist well
sometimes we got to deduce these
sometimes lost women become storm
chasers but they don't really know it
yet oh my god until mid mid storm
because i've seen chicks accidentally
become astronauts too they just oh how's
the house
they kind of like just somehow get into
like good schools and then like become
like pilots of fighter planes
and then i think probably because
they're really hot then they get
promoted to astronaut oh that makes
sense that's true because if i was an
astronaut
and i'm like damn do i really want to be
with nick in this space shuttle for like
the next [ __ ] year you want to spend
two years with this guy all right i'd
rather [ __ ] pick a hot girl yeah i
think you're absolutely right i mean
he's so boring i'd rather watch like
dupont paint just [ __ ] dry them on
the walls who exactly is stopping women
from being storm chasers it's not really
a job that there's like a storm dude
it's a [ __ ]
this it's the storm dude they're so
[ __ ] up the storm is sexist hell yeah
it's a sexist storm that's the [ __ ]
storm store marking dude isn't that like
an independent market like there's not
you don't have to get hired and
recruited not like a storm-chasing
recruitment officer little girl so
here's the thing are little girls
watching twister no they're not that's
true that's true when you watch those
movies such a sexist movie that's what
we need to start we need to start with a
female representation in storm chaser
movies that's exactly right that's where
it starts yeah like how angelina jolie
did tomb raider and then suddenly i
started paying attention to tombs yeah
yeah you're really into i was in the
fantasy what did she hunt in the first
place like what is her she's tomb raider
artists are in the
she's like indiana with jones but it's
indiana bones
oh yeah it's totally a new one
she screws my duck and she needs two
pistols with her at all i don't really
know because i was just looking at her
tits the whole time
yeah that's what happened to me did she
say anything in that movie nope when i
played the game i like to put her in
crosstalk accident i don't even know
where tomb raider came out in theaters
that was the first time i had sex in a
theater while the movie was playing oh
yeah
angelina jolie i was looking at it
i was looking at angelina jolie at the
same time
were you were you imagining her while
your dick was inside yeah it was imagine
lena jolie how are you how are you
[ __ ] her how are you giving it to her
pretty good um
it was more like she was just sitting
and doing her reverse congratulations so
she could watch the movie it's a low
contribution to this oh that was me in
x-men 2 x-men united
i never had sex in the theater guys were
you conflicted because you wanted to
watch the movie but you had to have
already seen it which x-men did you
choose to focus your attention to i
couldn't do this with my favorite dude
unfortunately
[Laughter]
juggernaut
unfortunately it was actually the part
of the movie where wolverine's like
[ __ ] slaying everybody in the mansion
i'm not kidding it sounds like so it's
bob stryker you focus on bob well the
boss so all that's going on but like
wolverine's like [ __ ] literally
stabbing all these dudes and this
chick's riding me and i'm like this is
something dude you're coming yeah i was
blowing bricks in there dude
that was the second movie i did that on
the first one was chicken run
run
how old were you sadly yes 16. why'd you
go to chicken run
i just have no idea why
because he couldn't get into a raided
army yeah he could get it to jiggle all
the way i don't know how many kids were
in that theater dude oh [ __ ] think about
well i technically i'm a kid oh yeah 16.
when i was going like when i was going
like second third base during half past
dead which is a steven small movie like
the last one they had in tears
what a mad movie to watch while you're
getting
thank you there was nobody else in the
theater though because you know
unfortunately that was why stephen's
goal no longer is in theaters anymore
because nobody [ __ ] went to that
movie
but i did multiple times with my
girlfriend at the time oh that must be
why i chose chicken around then because
no one was watching nobody watched
yeah nobody was watching that was it
that one movie theater on atlantic that
cost a dollar it's only rerun
the movies come like three months later
yeah and no there was one by the black
angus behind the other movie theater in
alhambra that's gone was that one holy
[ __ ] that was like the matinee one
that's why everybody has sex at yep yeah
i wish i had a story to contribute to
this it's okay it's not too late i'm
[ __ ] moving i've only got a history
of hand job
yeah you never had a handy in a movie
theater either hickey in a hand job
that's all hey did you ever get it handy
during the haunted mansion ride at
disney
no
that's that's the hot spot do you
remember that ride's a hot spot do you
remember the dinosaur ride at knotts
do you remember that it was kind of like
the honda matching ride but it was just
all dinosaurs that sounds really
familiar
and that was notorious for people having
sex and they would stop the ride
and then they would make an announcement
stop
stop stop they do that at hannah manchin
a lot they
[Laughter]
oh he's not talking to us we're reverse
calgary recorded they're pre-recorded oh
god yeah somebody like a dj just
pressing the right buttons at the right
time it's 69 but reverse cowgirl button
stop blowjobbing
so do you guys suppose a lot about women
about what they can do and what they
cannot all the time i have my own biases
i need to get rid of yeah what are some
biases you have about women
inequality and twister though
tawny dude it's a big thing twist her
you know i haven't seen
um that many um crab fishermen that are
women
why that's true
because they try to get rid of crabs
that's why no it's because there's no
movies
because there's no women want to get rid
of them
one deadly catch men are fighting for
them who's doing the [ __ ] car what
about ice road truckers if we showed
little girls videos of of girls doing
ice road truckers or a movie with a
chick who's like a ice road trucker then
yeah then girl more girls would do it
yeah that's the key it's a media thing
the more we put this the depiction
there's not enough role models thank you
not enough role models
yeah we need to have
more um
women in positions
of power
that
they can look up to that's right for
example
clowns
why is it always a man why is it always
a guy who likes killing people
touches kids and weird [ __ ] dudes
yeah that's true we need a female clown
that touches kids why not ronaldo
mcdonald
ronaldo it's because of the name i think
the fans are female priests there's a
ring huh mix it up a little bit like a
nun
no a female priest
female priest is that like a priest like
a nun yeah but instead of calling them
the like uh father
the mother they call her mother and then
maybe maybe less maybe less molestations
will happen that's true to all the altar
boys you know i know so less complaints
just remember the next next time you're
watching footage of a tornado that was
done by a person who is called a storm
chaser they hunt tornadoes and is
probably sold to a media outlet um by a
man but that could have been a woman too
and just remember that and don't suppose
too much thank you
in the catholic church is there any
position that the women can get higher
than the preacher hell no it's catholic
dude yeah no
there shouldn't be a female
so the glass the ceiling is much lower
for women in the catholic church of
course the woman could be up the popa
but she can't be the pope she can become
a nun aka nothing else after oh man
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you